Transcription: Manon Armenoult
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Ce n’est pas souvent
qu’on vient suivi d’une caméra.
Tout va bien.
I’m strong.
I’m smart.
I’m beautiful.
Levez la main si vous vous êtes dit
une de ces trois phrases aujourd’hui.
Ce n’est pas mal, bravo !
Maintenant, levez la main
si vous vous les dites tous les jours.
Il y a quand même
quelques personnes, bravo !
Maintenant, on va faire un autre test,
d’autres types de phrases.
« Je ne sais pas », « Je ne peux pas »,
« Je ne vais pas y arriver ».
Vous voyez où je veux en venir ?
Levez la main si vous vous les dites
tous les jours.
Ou aujourd'hui.
Je ne la lève pas parce qu’aujourd’hui,
je ne me le suis pas dit.
(rire)
Êtes-vous surpris du résultat ?
Je pense que non.
Moi, je ne le suis pas en tout cas.
Nous avons tous,
et surtout nous les femmes,
tendance à douter de nous
et de nos capacités
plutôt que de se dire :
« Je vais y arriver. »
Pourquoi est-ce important ?
Parce que la confiance en soi
est une des choses essentielles
pour être à la hauteur de nos ambitions.
Vous le savez tous,
nous n’avons pas assez de femmes leaders.
Réfléchissez.
Combien d’hommes leaders
êtes-vous capables de nommer en France ?
Vous avez une idée en tête ?
Maintenant, posez-vous la question :
combien de femmes leaders
êtes-vous capables de nommer en France ?
De plus en plus, certes,
mais assurément pas assez.
Uniquement trois femmes à la tête
des entreprises CAC 40 en France.
Un peu plus de 10% de dirigeantes
d’entreprises SBF 120.
Puis seulement le tiers des entrepreneurs
en France sont des femmes.
La progression est lente
et pourtant nous souhaitons l’égalité.
Mais se dire un message positif
ne suffit évidemment pas.
Aujourd’hui, nous avons
beaucoup plus de possibilités
pour devenir des femmes leaders
ou même des hommes leaders
ou être à la hauteur de nos ambitions.
Premièrement, il y a dix ans,
la loi Copé-Zimmermann
a imposé des quotas de femmes
dans les conseils d'administration
des entreprises.
De nouveaux programmes ont été lancés
pour pousser la femme
à devenir une leadeuse.
Puis de plus en plus de rôles modèles,
en ouvrant la voie,
non seulement nous montre le chemin,
mais peuvent en plus
nous donner des conseils guidés
et des petits coups de pouce.
Mais alors, concrètement, comment faire ?
Qu’allez-vous,
chacun et chacune d’entre vous,
pouvoir faire aujourd’hui,
demain et tous les jours
pour être à la hauteur de vos ambitions ?
Pour vous aider, je vais vous raconter
une petite histoire.
C’est l’histoire d’une petite fille
qui s’appelle Audacia.
Audacia rêve d’être une grande dirigeante.
Petite, elle ne sait pas encore
que ça s’appelle « Femme leader ».
Audacia est née en Arménie,
un pays où finalement,
à l’époque où elle est née,
la place de la femme leader
n’était qu’à la cuisine.
Et encore.
Petite, elle rêve d’être entrepreneuse
et enseignante.
Normal, son père est entrepreneur
et sa mère enseignante.
Comment aurait-elle pu imaginer à six ans
qu’il y aurait un monde, un jour,
où ça serait possible.
À treize ans, Audacia déménage
dans un nouveau pays.
Nouveau pays, nouvelle culture,
nouvelle éducation.
Il faut tout réapprendre,
y compris la langue.
C’est dur, mais ce n’est pas grave.
Elle prend sur elle
et malgré tout, elle réussit.
De grandes études,
de nouveaux amis,
et un super travail.
Tout se passe bien.
Et puis elle tombe amoureuse.
Amoureuse d’un nouveau pays.
Un pays qui est encore plus loin :
la France.
Maintenant,
imaginez Audacia
dans un moment fatidique de sa vie,
du haut de ses 22 ans,
à l’aéroport Charles de Gaulle,
pour la première fois en France,
après de longues heures de vol,
elle est là,
il ne lui reste plus qu’à sortir
pour qu’une nouvelle vie commence.
Une nouvelle vie dont elle a rêvé,
qu’elle a choisie et qu’elle a organisée.
Un seul pas.
Sauf qu’elle n’y arrive pas.
Elle est tétanisée devant cette porte,
elle n’arrive pas à avancer.
Comment faire ?
Grosse panique.
Alors Audacia se rappelle
qu’elle a un des principaux atouts
pour devenir une femme leader.
Le « growth mindset ».
Vous savez, cet état d’esprit
qui, non seulement,
vous donne de la confiance,
mais en plus de la résilience
et la détermination nécessaire
pour aller vers votre rêve.
Et puis, elle va utiliser
une de ces poses ou des techniques
dont elle a beaucoup entendu parler
dans des livres et des séries :
the power pose.
Vous savez ce que c’est ?
C’est un sentiment de position de pouvoir
qui vous donne la confiance nécessaire
à un instant T.
Un réel sentiment
de position de pouvoir à l’instant T.
Alors elle prend la pose.
Je vais vous montrer.
Je suis forte.
Je suis intelligente.
Je vais y arriver.
Et elle franchit le pas.
Bon, je vais vous donner un petit secret,
ma power pose, c’est des talons.
C’est pour ça
que je suis en talons aujourd’hui,
vous l’aurez remarqué.
Et Audacia alors ?
Après avoir été bien ancrée
dans une bonne vie
où elle avait du travail
et une vie sociale,
la voilà dans un nouveau pays.
De nouveau, nouvelle éducation,
de nouveaux amis et une nouvelle langue.
Et surtout, pour la troisième fois,
il faut tout apprendre,
désapprendre et réapprendre.
Mais aussi, il faut absolument
trouver un travail.
Car inimaginable pour Audacia
de ne pas avoir un travail.
Et donc on recommence.
Recherches, entretiens, refus.
Et bien sûr, des bonnes nouvelles.
Savez-vous que selon les études,
un homme postule à un job
s’il a 60% des compétences
alors qu’une femme va postuler
quand elle en a 100%.
Quant à Audacia, elle postule
même si elle en a 60%.
Vous savez pourquoi ?
Premièrement, parce qu’elle sait
qu’elle est capable d’apprendre vite.
Et si elle sait déjà tout sur le job,
quel est le challenge ?
Comment sait-elle
qu’elle sait apprendre vite ?
En fait, Audacia ne s’est jamais
arrêtée d’apprendre.
Elle adore apprendre.
À vrai dire, elle est ce qu’on appelle
une « lifelong learner ».
D’ailleurs, son livre de chevet,
c’est « My personal MBA ».
C’est un concept, vous le connaissez ?
On va en parler.
Aujourd’hui, nous avons finalement accès
à un nombre de ressources illimitées
pour la formation et l’apprentissage.
On a des livres physiques,
des livres numériques et des livres audio.
Des formations en ligne.
Des Ted Talk.
On a aussi des présentations
des meilleurs speakers
gratuitement mises en ligne.
Qu’est-ce qu’il nous reste à faire ?
Apprendre.
Le concept de « My personal MBA » alors ?
Le concept est assez simple
parce qu’il faut juste créer un plan.
Donc chacun et chacune d’entre vous
créent son propre plan d’apprentissage
pour choisir les compétences à apprendre,
sur quel temps donné.
Puis on apprend.
Audacia s’était fixée deux objectifs.
Premièrement, elle allait écouter
un livre par semaine.
D’ailleurs, elle écoute des livres
en marchant, en courant, en conduisant.
Et puis elle allait faire
une formation en ligne par mois.
Tout cela ensemble,
ça allait lui permettre de connaître
son sujet a minima,
un nouveau sujet par mois.
Couplé avec son diplôme d’école,
Audacia avait donc l’avantage
sur le marché de l’emploi.
Parce qu’en fait, elle a très bien compris
que pour trouver le job de ses rêves,
elle a besoin d’être deux fois meilleure.
C’est : « growth mindset »
et les compétences.
Qu’est-ce qu’il lui reste ?
Des idées ?
Le réseau.
Il reste le réseau et la visibilité.
On va faire un autre test.
Pas besoin de lever la main cette fois.
Réfléchissez dans votre tête.
Selon vous,
qui juge le plus sévèrement
les femmes ?
Les hommes ou les femmes elles-mêmes ?
Certains d’entre vous seront surpris
parce que d’autres connaissent la réponse.
En effet, les études montrent
qu’une femme est jugée négativement à 70%
par les femmes elles-mêmes.
Et uniquement à 30% par les hommes.
On pourrait de nouveau dire
« Et alors ? ».
Et alors,
la conséquence de tout cela,
c’est que les femmes ne parlent pas.
Parce qu’en plus,
elles sont extrêmement sensibles
au jugement des autres.
Donc elles ne parlent plus.
Elles n’osent pas se montrer.
Et puis à chaque fois
qu’elles ont de superbes réalisations
et des bonnes ambitions,
finalement, elles ne vont rien dire.
Alors, à quoi bon avoir
de superbes réalisations et ambitions
quand on ne veut pas en parler ?
Parce qu’en fait, quand on en parle pas,
ça amène vers quoi ?
Manque de visibilité.
Et le manque de visibilité
amène vers un manque de réseau.
Et le manque de réseau
freine le devenir d’une femme leader.
Parce qu'en fait, on en a tous besoin.
On a besoin d’un coach, d’un mentor
ou d’un sponsor.
C’est-à-dire des personnes
qui nous connaissent assez bien,
avec nos compétences,
pour, à un moment opportun,
parler de nous.
Et Audacia alors ?
Audacia était dans un nouveau pays
où, assurément,
elle ne connaissait pas grand monde.
D’ailleurs, elle travaillait,
donc, elle avait un agenda très chargé.
Mais ce point était vraiment primordial
pour son épanouissement à Paris.
Alors, elle a fait un autre plan.
Bon, vous aurez compris,
elle adore les plans.
Dans ce plan,
il y avait deux autres points.
Premièrement, elle s’était fixé
pour objectif d’aller déjeuner
avec une nouvelle personne par mois.
Puis le deuxième point,
c’était d’aller a minima
à un événement professionnel par mois.
Ça lui permettait de rencontrer
de nouvelles personnes.
Pourquoi rencontrer
de nouvelles personnes ?
Parce que les gens passionnants
et passionnés par leur métier
allaient pouvoir lui donner
toutes les informations
sur ces nouveaux métiers.
Vous connaissez le livre
« Never eat alone » ?
Oui ?
Si vous ne connaissez pas, regardez.
Un livre qui, déjà il y a quinze ans,
parlait de l’importance du réseau.
L’idée est finalement assez simple :
profiter de ce moment convivial du repas
pour connaître une nouvelle personne.
Attention, pour connaître
une nouvelle personne
dans une démarche uniquement
de curiosité et non intéressée,
mais pas pour lui demander
un travail ou un service.
L'idée, c'est qu'on discute,
on fait connaissance.
Et à terme, peut-être que cette personne
deviendra un ami proche
ou alors une superbe
connaissance professionnelle.
Vous devriez essayer.
Parce qu’en fait vous ne serez pas déçus.
Ouvrez-vous aux nouvelles personnes.
Grâce à ce troisième point manquant,
Audacia,
avait tout ce qu’il fallait
pour être une femme leader.
Et finalement,
sans se rendre compte du chemin parcouru,
elle était épanouie.
Elle avait le job de ses rêves,
elle avait son entreprise
et elle enseignait.
Et puis, cerise sur le gâteau,
elle était entourée
par des gens passionnants.
Et là on s’attend au happy ending :
« Elle vécu heureuse
jusqu’à la fin de sa vie. »
Et pourquoi pas ?
Tout est possible.
Mais ce qui est important,
c’est qu’Audacia a compris
que rien n’arrive
par un coup de baguette magique,
qu’il faut travailler.
Alors, vous l’aurez probablement compris,
cette petite fille, Audacia, c’est moi,
mais pas que moi.
Dans chacun et chacune d’entre vous,
il y a un ou une Audacia.
Et en tant qu’Audacia,
vous devez absolument travailler
les trois points essentiels
pour devenir de vrais leaders :
votre état d’esprit,
vos compétences et votre réseau.
Il faut surtout faire passer ce message
à toutes les petites filles.
J’en vois quelques-unes dans la salle
- et aux petits garçons -,
à tout la jeune génération.
Car si nous tous ensemble, on y croit,
elles vont y arriver.
Et vous savez comment
je sais que tout est possible ?
Parce que tout à l’heure,
avant de monter sur scène,
en prenant ma power pose,
je me suis dit :
« Je suis forte, je suis intelligente
et tellement plus. »
(Applaudissements)
Merci.